hi I'm Evan Carmichael and welcome to
another edition of ask Evan in today's
video I'm going to answer question from
a teacher who's a reader of mine named
Jean Pierre who wrote in asking about a
squashing that one of a jumpier students
hi so the question is I want to know
what are the characteristics of the
startup phase of a small business Thanks
your time jump here so jump hear the
startup phase of a new business is
really all about survival it's making
enough money to be able to support
yourself and get by and not have to go
get a job and that's really the biggest
challenge that most entrepreneurs have
when they're starting the business is
getting it to the point where they can
sustain themselves so you're looking for
opportunities trying to build around
different challenges that you might be
able to solve and that's really the
biggest challenge that most
entrepreneurs face the business model
that you come up with is really going to
be the business model that you end up
with so change is going to have to be
made and that's a huge challenge for
most startup entrepreneurs is working on
that business model until you hit one
that works that is going to generate a
lot of money and help you grow your
business my best advice if you're in
that phase if you're thinking of certain
business oh you've just started go out
and talk to customers the best feedback
you can get is from customers who have a
challenge and you can help them solve it
and they're willing to pay you to solve
that challenge so if you haven't started
your business just go out and start
talking to customers find out what the
problems are find out how you might be
able to help them and see if they'd be
willing to pay you to help them that's a
winning customer if you can build your
business around these types of customers
then you have money coming into the
company you're not struggling to figure
out is this idea going to work or not
because you have those paying customers
and you're much more likely to be
successful so I hope that helps you up
here if you guys liked the video please
give it a thumbs up below I'd also love
to hear your thoughts and feedback if
you want to leave a comment under the
video and stay tuned to next episode
you